l'ensemble de la tâche aisée
[Applaudissements]
je me suis occupé niacine yacine dit la
vérité c'est vrai regardez sa nouvelle
barre à la vérité à la proximité avec
ses employés il dessine ma propre
bonheur leur dis la vérité je me sens
toujours pas mieux je me sens c'est un
nouvel an ah non mais je me sens moins
fiche des récits carton moi je voudrais
faire chauffer de bézieux avait terminé
pour la banque c'est là même que vous
bah oui c'est vrai il n'y a pas de trou
assez gros dans ces magnifiques affine
éclaircies merci ça rajoute alors voir
la même chose
tiffany si vous voulez
[Rires]
en ce moment les deux plus gros mystère
du moment sont la ligue des champions
va-t-elle continuer cyril va-t-il passer
sur canal+
cyril je savais que tu avais de lego
frangin mais je dis tu as carrément fait
un débat sur toi même c'est que franck
appietto a dans la tête que je bifurque
sur quade a pu s'en donner votre avis ah
bon alors là c'est facile quoi oui
pardon 20e pensez vous évidemment oui
serait très très fort de le faire
d'abord le seul problème s'est dépouillé
une chaîne pour valoriser notre corps a
besoin
en clair de remonter les audiences en
clair de canal et ce serait une
merveilleuse idée bien sûr bernard bien
sûr réseau universel c'est pas tout tu
t'es même auto teese est très rare
garder voire on va voir la séquence et
après je vous reparle et parce que tout
le monde parle alors canal+ canal+
je vous en parlais même les chroniqueurs
est ce que comme des fous voilà bon il
ya plein de gens qui me disent alors
canal+ ou pas je vous réponds dans un
instant parce qu'ils sont pas bien là
donc un mec qui parle autant lui
franchement tu a rappelé le professeur
raoul tu j'attends le jour où tu vas
arriver tu vas dire dans un instant aux
soins invité exceptionnel mois aulas a
mais moi je connais ta technique tu
pousses ton émission et tu la pousse à
bout pour partir de ces huit ans fait
donc la semaine dernière tu as reçu une
femme voilée une complotisme une
bouteille d'evian
c'est une fois fabrice division est les
patrons de médias ça fait quand même
beaucoup la série ne situe pas sur la
main l'année prochaine la nature a donc
les droits du foot les droits du rugby
et les droits de cyrine mais attention
c'est il sur canal et aussi la formule 1
et je te connais tu serais capable de
dire hamilton mérou blitz à 9 heures
voilà un ce que ton public suivra
beaucoup dit ça je ne pense pas que nos
téléspectateurs soit plus bêtes que les
autres
passer de la chaîne 8 à 4 il devrait y
arriver je vous montre au cas où regard
des attentes
salah très simple alors je vois arriver
la question si cyril va sur canal qui va
le remplacer sur ces 8 à ces qui a dit
qu'il quitte et si je ne suis procuré la
grille des programmes de l'année
prochaine regarder dans le détail voici
les émissions 8h 12h debout ligne ou
voilà pour réveiller les enfants dans la
barthe à 12h 14h avec ou sans rice à une
émission culinaire hors norme
14 14 heures 16 heures santa barbara
l'affectons passionnant d'ailleurs voici
un extrait les amis je viens d'apprendre
une terrible nouvelle
vas-y accouche tpm paix va passer sur
canal+ en quotidienne et du coup on ne
sera plus sur ces huit quoi oui je sais
et du coup cyril va devoir devenir vegan
portaient des stan smith et des
pantalons aux ourlets de pas cyril ça
non c'est pas cyril qu'est ce qu'on va
faire de vrd
[Applaudissements]
écoute je te jure gilles audette tu
viens d'écrire un livre à l'incertain
comment la vidéo elle est c'est vrai le
bas magazine de l'éco regarder tous les
cours de la bourse commenté par cyril
par exemple l'action de sanofi chute de
4% réaction terrible
18h18 en une point soleil avec bernard
montiel 18 ans une 18h30 fachos pas
facho présentés par gilbert des là qui
nous dira ce qui est anti musulman ce
qu'il n'est pas tout de suite un extrait
regard des premiers tweets premier tweet
rtg nication d'evian pour moi je vais
envoyer un mot fort c'est de
l'islamophobie commercial c'est-à-dire
que vous faites exprès de taper de
provoquer de taper sur les musulmans
vous ils ont fait ça si elles savent
très bien c'est sciemment et ils se
foutent du bad buzz parce que c'est du
buzz depuis quatre jours les musulmans
par l'ats gilles verdez comme si on
était dans fort boyard sort 9h coucou
les relous une émission dans laquelle
marlène schiappa nous présentera chaque
jour à quartier rôle où tout de suite un
extrait regardez là l'idée c'était
vraiment d'avoir un truc impactants en
politique il ya beaucoup de sigles et je
trouvais c'est un petit clin d'oeil de
dire moi je vais fonder des culs et
cerfs et les gens sont très serrés nous
avons qu'est ce que c'est dès qu un
essai regina des quartiers sans relou
voilà est évidemment steve est aussi
raison quand il dit qu'il faut que ce
soit tout le territoire
mais l'idée pour nous c'est vraiment
d'avoir un baromètre des zones rouges
ouais c'est clair 19e
battant un 19 heures là ça devient pique
nique cyril par sur canal pour faire tpm
plus en vélo électrique grâce à notre
partenaire qu'on salue et il reviendra
toutes les 10 minutes sur ces 8 pour
présent présenté tpp plus ou moins et
enfin cyril se rassure c'est ce quart de
minuit à 6 heures du matin pour
présenter des clips alors cyril je te
rappelle que dans une journée ya 24
heures et ta famille a besoin de toi
bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]